hey you bozos do yourselves a favor come
out and see the boys live oh yeah stand
up comedy show we play a little ayg with
the crowd fantastic way to introduce new
people to the show so bring the whole
gang out come see us yeah guys get your
best girlfriend your best boyfriend the
group chat your homies the bozos anybody
we're gonna be in Red Bank New Jersey uh
in August that show's about to sell out
then we're going to Seattle Portland
Kansas City Springfield St Louis
Nashville in the Philadelphia Providence
Rhode Island Boston Atlanta get those
tickets we'll see you there yeah welcome
to another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage sure is a little
shall we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out the group to
be classy yeah they're just a bagel
piece of trash I'm your host Dave Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at antuti's basement she's
upstairs on the StubHub trying to book
some backstage passes to that Elton John
farewell tour okay she says she can turn
them okay see what she's gonna do she
does got that mustache rocking so I
don't know sure okay my co-host is
coming at you I'm right next to me he is
the CEO of are you garbage he is an
international businessman and he is not
to be trifled with gang he's the prince
of Park Avenue but always the king of
the boardwalk give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan Hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure your rate of
you subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are
[ __ ] and then obviously the greatest
goddamn website of all time I owe my
whole life to this goddamn [ __ ]
website
www.patreon.com you're signing up your
bonus content you get episodes of ayg
every week you get bonus episodes of
hard feeling every week which is
completely different podcast a little
behind the curtain a lot of fighting
that's where the eyebrows hit the road
you know what I mean better believe it
what's going on over there hey zip it
Shanghai
I look like a goddamn Skyline over here
all right
I am just like Tokyo guys how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer X
Jordan Air the magic man makes us all
look good he works the ones and twos he
crosses the t's and dots the eyes give
it up for our good pal Toby McMullen
everybody what's up dudes what up T-Bone
it's a beautiful day in New York City
sun shining it's summertime perfect day
for a little sweet tea
[Applause]
Tommy Maps over here
gang we couldn't be more excited
look at this your road dog it's all back
in the roads I don't even like looking
at you in New York City
don't talk to me unless we're in Albany
okay gang we couldn't be more excited to
have our incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guest back with us
again today he's one of the year one of
the OG's we've been together since
[ __ ] Jump Street started out on a
hard Street to Philly together you can
see him on the live shows he comes
everywhere with us and he has a brand
new album out right now called life
after funny it is his sophomore album it
is available on YouTube right now and
will be available on all streaming
platforms tomorrow July 15th make sure
you check it out give it up for the
pride of Roxboro PA the second most
famous guy to ever come out of Roxboro
PA Mr Tom Cassidy not me nobody thought
I'd be back I'm here baby contractually
we had to have you let's get them views
up come on I don't know why you [ __ ]
go I don't know why you're wearing your
pajamas hey Ebenezer
go back to bed will you uh who's the
first most famous person to come out of
Roxbury I mean there's got to be
somebody this guy stinks what do you
mean Kevin's cousin Stevie yes
somebody had to hit a scratch off or
somewhere baby yeah sure buddy
congratulations on the album thank you
very much life after funny yeah second
album baby check it out on YouTube right
now 30 minutes of heat fully hosted for
me made fun of them up top let's get the
views out there you go you know Grace
Kelly lived in Roxboro the princess not
garbage at all pretty classy Monaco
heard of it she get hit by a bus or
something like something like that
she can call turning odometers back
what's going on a fat guy in a panda
shirt pushed her
uh also we got some nuptials coming up
here getting married in October getting
married everybody's invited Toby's going
I didn't think I was going to get the
invite to be honest with you I was on
there you're paying for half of this I
was on the fence till he started coming
on the road with us are you kidding me
you're talking about I think you're
walking her down the aisle not giving
her away
I'm allowed to kiss her
she got mad at me because I was
FaceTiming with Foley on the LIRR going
to Long Beach on Sunday and I had her
try to show him a little shoulder ah
she's so upset I got a little peek
she knows who's keeping the lights on
over at that dump cough it up honey
what's the honeymoon situation we have
the first half uh
we're doing an increment of Jesus we're
gonna hit Dover Delaware and then we're
gonna go up to Cinnaminson New Jersey
you're the first guy to put a honeymoon
on layaway all right we got the second
half on layaway right now you gotta go
somewhere and get jobs
[Laughter]
out front of a Home Depot waiting to get
picked up what what Amazon Distributing
Center are you [ __ ] staying at we're
starting the first part in uh San
Francisco shout out to San Francisco and
all the places on the road that we've
been what a beautiful sure except for
Phoenix
[Laughter]
who goes on their honeymoon in the
continental United States I guess I mean
yeah what are you talking about I mean I
was thinking Sandia who goes the same
for San Francisco's gonna be cold in
October all right what it was cold when
we were there and [ __ ] take it easy
so we're going October I'm sorry we're
going to San Francisco catch a Giants
game
my mom got his tickets they're in the
World Series maybe
you're scalping tickets on your honey
October um but uh so San Francisco from
Wednesday to Saturday he's out there in
a kayak trying to catch a home run so a
couple days out there yeah
that's San Fran hold on dude hold on
hold on oh Wednesday it's on Saturday
what is this a business trip first part
of the first part of the trip stay in
the first part he's a loser
he's got no money
what Tuesday in October is The Wedding
by the way first of all it's on a Sunday
on October 9th thank you very much and
it's a holiday for me to break into the
church
we're doing it by the lake just blend it
into the nine o'clock mass so anyway to
get back on topic so Sanford from
Wednesday to Saturday morning then from
Saturday morning we're driving up to
Yosemite and I got a cabin in like near
Yosemite from Saturday to Monday because
I don't know how long I want to be up in
the [ __ ] Woods sure I just want like
one hard day at Yosemite uh-huh and then
so that's where we're at right now
putting prospected up there
we're looking for a way yeah bring your
sifters guys we're paying for gold up in
these parts that's to pay for the second
half of the trip
he heard about Uganda hitting it big but
then uh no
Uganda just found a seven trillion
dollar uh gold deposit and you just sake
bombed
a couple more sake bombs over here for
the big fella huh
right part over here
um and then the second can you turn his
shirt down for us
these are all LEDs do it in post touch
it you feel any heat coming off and then
here at humming what are you talking
about I remember that episode Kramer
slept right next to it
um
to Kenny Rogers yeah it was an unclear
joke sorry uh and then the second part
of the trip I think we're going to Palm
Springs
but we have wherever the train takes you
yeah we haven't booked that yet Palm
Springs California yeah where else okay
I don't know Palm Springs in Florida
um probably yeah I'm sure don't act like
who to California we're looking all over
California a beautiful state all right
by San Fran though or SF is the cool
guys call it you know she wanted to go
to San Francisco this is basically what
she wants to do and she's my sweet baby
girl so and it's what's on budget and uh
of the credit cards and uh so yeah
that's why I I would have gone I like
the beach and [ __ ] but she's not like as
much where would you have gone what's
your dream honey no not even dream that
you could go and afford like what was
like what was what would have been your
choice she goes hey babe listen Tomcat
you had the special come out home run
you deserve it where do you want to go
you choose the honeymoon Parks Casino
wherever
we're on tour next Indianapolis
Jersey let's go
uh Andy's nice Camden no Hawaii probably
okay something like that okay yeah there
you go say Hawaii nice Beach area
that's way different than San Fran on a
Tuesday
well I mean I'm imagining Tim Fran and
you're camping one for for two nights in
the park sure first of all it's a nice
cabin it's not we're not it's not a year
okay okay but that supply chain issue
that cargo ship would take a long time
ago I need to use up on this [ __ ]
thing no but um
the only guy I have no accounts accounts
of the views of his appearance and the
last one's at about 4 000. it's at 16
429. but uh Louis beat you in about 30
seconds
Louie beat you before he was released I
know that was funny right first time you
said it to me because that was a Gippy
yeah it takes you I said How's Louie
doing it it's your ghost writer I was
[ __ ] on you via text and he said he
said he beat Cassidy in about 10 minutes
Toby cut it
but yeah so you know we're excited
that's good the honeymoon will be fun
and uh you know the wedding's right
around the corner a lot a lot of stuff
going on we're excited we're happy for
you got the hotel and you're not doing a
band you're doing a DJ right yeah DJ
okay curate it music playlist by me okay
yeah this would be the battles from
eight mile are gonna be on there you're
not playing any of your album at the
wedding right yeah there's a viewing
party I think I'm thinking about having
hard copies ah you know don't do that
it's a nice gift is there gifts they're
coming because you don't really have a
Grooms you don't have any groomsmen you
have a best man yeah Sammy rubinoff our
good pass doctor Sam rubinoff which I
still haven't heard anything about the
[ __ ] bachelor party I don't think
there's gonna be one where are we going
to be in August
yeah I'll take you to Seattle for your
bachelor party we're going to Dave and
Buster's aren't we
we are going to David kill two birds
with one stone get a couple hookers
we'll be in Times Square they're they're
right there baby yeah these guys dick
selected
never-ending breadsticks oh my God
do you want that do you want the
traditional bachelor party then you know
the titty bar the
not really I mean I would but I don't
really need it or want it that much I
feel like she was kind of against it too
like it'd be weird if she was for it
right yeah hey go have some trouble I'm
not she's not doing well yeah I was
gonna say what she no she's going to
chip in the house
she's got to be scooting around with a
couple of her friends she's going down
the sandals with her friend Enrique
they're gonna play the boards for a few
days
but uh yeah no like people are coming to
this uh is this a black tie affair we're
doing up in where we Syracuse it's in
Auburn New York the Finger Lakes
beautiful area uh it's you know it's
formal uh I still have to get my home
jerseys
no white
the bride's family's wearing away
shirts for skins
um so it's like 200 I think is pretty
big that's the amount of people who are
invited but you know you don't know how
many people 400 show up I bet you're
praying [ __ ] have fun don't show up
nah it's all been Tommy's praying for a
blizzard on his wedding
well we're excited for you we're happy
what are you giving them card wise this
is big this is you know this is a big
thing we ask all these you know these
these famous guests that come through we
asked them what they give at weddings
what are you gonna give to our friend
Tom Cassidy I'm giving more than anybody
else at that wedding I can guarantee
there's no way that's gonna happen why
because you don't have it
yeah but your family's all bozos
yeah
sorry you stumped me on that [ __ ] get a
couple of scratchers from Genie I mean
it's there's gonna be four numbers I
know that you're giving him a thousand
dollars probably to be honest with you
okay he's my you know one of my best
friends we started comedy together he's
always been [ __ ] good to me that'll
be easy because he just let me borrow a
thousand dollars
I'll just hand it right back to him
it's like Lefty to the cards for me big
guy
thank you yeah you're welcome it all
comes full circle you just asked me for
a Jihad on the wrist
and I wasn't gonna bring that up what
are you doing there in our business he's
a dirtbag I don't want people to know
what I got money on the street are you
charging him a big furnace or what's
happening okay I'm beansy I wasn't even
gonna ask for it back to be honest with
you and then yeah I was gonna get it all
right we got that on tape yeah
hey yeah
um but that can't be your wedding thing
present
because no matter what then I look like
a dirt ball to your girl I gotta hand
you an envelope with something in it
that said I already gave Tommy a jihot I
don't know what Tommy's been telling you
Hey listen you know you borrow money
sometimes he borrowed money from me when
he was down in that yeah you know before
he could afford all of that uh dog spray
he puts in his hand how much putting
more and more of that in there aren't
you Jesus Christ I'm hooked on the sun
and I'm telling you like one of the
[ __ ] old Baldwin brothers on coke
with that amount of [ __ ] blonde in
your head it is weird yeah I'm hooked on
it I love it put some in the beard
straighten it out a little bit he can't
do that there's too many colors I would
argue he can't do the top dude you look
like a safty Brothers movie
yeah deep cut but okay all right
all right let's get back on track what
are you giving them that you're running
your mouth I don't know uh I was gonna
maybe 500 it's five's nice I was gonna
give him a firm handshake with some eye
contact yeah what are you talking about
what do you need Xbox money you already
got it what the [ __ ] are you talking
about yeah 500 I think is admirable sure
very nice I gotta fly to this goddamn
wedding
I mean you got to think I'm like one of
your first employees so 500 is good you
know yeah it's good it's a nice boss
yeah you gotta talk to yourself in a
450. why I'm saying it's good I know you
talked about what the uh what the
entrees were which isn't great one of
the accommodations what hotel are we
staying at because I might get the
honeymoon suite before you guys check in
I forget what it's it's a hotel he said
there's he's he said you should hurry up
because there's the good hotel in the
other Hotel there's a better Hotel yeah
well that should be reserved for the you
know yeah maybe for dignitaries I mean
you could get it now I send you a save
to date it's got all that information on
it wait we don't get hotels what's the
door deal on this thing I'm getting
Bamboozled here
I gotta make the money back somehow big
man's out a thousand I'm out 500 we
gotta [ __ ] I gotta recruit my losses
is there a cocktail hour of course is it
open bar yes for how long 25 minutes
baby
you can have whatever you like but are
we doing top shelf or what are we doing
what are we at the Ritz Carlton what are
you talking about it's good it's okay
it's the mid mid-range yeah
what do you mean no the venue does okay
well some places I've had that where you
show up and like to like the the groom's
walking in a case of Jack and you're
like this is gonna be yeah sometimes you
compartmentalize it like you you supply
your liquor and they and like we'll
bring the booze you guys staff the bar
bring your own appetizers wedding no but
I'll be surprised
um but thanks for coming everybody it's
five dollars a cup
we're gonna be pissing a bucket around
in a little bit they're solo wine
glasses
yeah not too shabby but uh yeah it's a
it's you know her family's classy you
know for Upstate New York however classy
that can be you know I imagine there'll
be some camo somewhere in this wedding I
don't think so there's going to be a set
of dungarees walking around somebody's
going to be wearing a baseball hat I'm
sure of it I went to her brother's
wedding last summer which was also in
Upstate New York and one of the people
got kicked out because he took his shirt
off oh I can't believe T-Bone bring the
cameras
the next patreon goal is Tom Cat Daddy
Cassidy's wedding
and uh he like pissed in the parking lot
so there's like that type of [ __ ] but
that was her brother's friend he's not
gonna be they sound classy he was a nice
guy
also in defense I mean I've definitely
been to uh I've had some weddings in my
family where there's been some Ravel
rousing for sure oh yeah it's just not a
good look to take your shirt off at a
wedding no sure and later on somebody
else took it with a maid of honor
does she have a lineup of broads does
she have that one Made of Honor just one
maid of honor yeah I think you're gonna
get lucky that night big fella take a
run at her trying to get a third huh try
to hook up with Ruben off I don't know
if I should do this I fell at a wedding
one time all [ __ ] up
and uh on the dance oh the Dance Floor
was concrete it was like that smooth
concrete nice place out in the yard
it was in a parking garage you got
shanked no but it was like it was like a
nice event so like one of those cool
event spaces and like Fishtown it was
like nice it was nice but like it was
like and it had an industrial vibe
someone spilled a drink probably me and
it was it was it was is one of those
Falls where some [ __ ] puked and I
slipped in it it was one of those Falls
where I didn't fall the ground came up
and hit me type like you know that
feeling where you're like I didn't my
equilibrium didn't move I just got hit
in the head but it was like Inception
yeah it came up and whacked me on the
side I was all fine I gotta do spilled
it or whatever you gotta you look like a
real [ __ ] Bowser and people come to
help you yeah you're like I got it
Knocking over the grandma it's a tough
look we were at uh somebody's wedding
down in Maryland uh my it was my my boy
Jackson was getting married
um and my brother was there everybody
was on the dance floor and some we were
outside having a smoke or something like
that all of a sudden I just see my
brother go flying through the door
because they were it was like a mosh pit
or something they were like dancing
really hard and he got pushed back and
through the door and somebody put some
Limp Biscuit on let's get this thing
[ __ ] cooking
hey dude it was just like what the [ __ ]
man and he [ __ ] dude every my cousin
fell and [ __ ] this one fell it's a
bad luck and the one dude was like real
drunk he looked like a [ __ ] Turtle
Lane
that's when you know though wrap it up
[Music]
do you guys have any weird I mean
because you're a dirtbag you know do you
have any weird any weird plans for the
number for the consummation I know it's
a Philly fanatic gonna be there I mean
is there any weird I had Philly fanatic
at a wedding my friend's wedding
actually came here signed by the
Phillies I know someone someone had as a
guest or what yeah he came in for like
an hour danced and stuff yeah I know I
know someone had swoop and that was like
swoop yeah the Eagles oh yeah duh that's
not bad they had I mean like this guy's
like
they're worth like tens of millions of
dollars and they had [ __ ] he showed
up it was a black guy Affair it was real
[ __ ] everybody was bragging about
that yeah yeah I would love to have the
thing but do you guys do the thing with
like the tire on the head and the zipper
or what you know anything do you think
I'm gonna do that stuff I don't know any
games carry around the head yeah I don't
know what the [ __ ] is that you've never
seen that where like all the guys put
the I've never had it at a wedding but
you see it on like America's Funniest
Videos which I assume will end up on
somehow well like you put the tire on
the head at a wedding no I know we've
gone we we've talked about this we we
did the the upstate Pennsylvania thing
where you have all the guys are in a
circle and the brides
the bride's on the dance floor and the
groom has to push his way through yeah
this like high on the head at a wedding
people do
but isn't that just them being silly is
that a game I don't know I think it's a
bit of a thing yeah I don't think I'm
gonna do that now I'm gonna start I'm
just giving you I'm laying the
groundwork for when I try I think you
could be there for sure if he's doing
the worm okay let's talk about ladder
ladder ladder come on let's do it baby
life is fragile you don't want to leave
your family old in a bag what you need
is a little Durham life insurance and
Ladder can help you out with that yeah
guys the rising cost of living is
[ __ ] cooking right now goddamn
inflation gas prices student loan debt
you're trying to buy a house and you
don't want to leave your kids or partner
in a huge financial burden ladder is 100
digital there's no doctors no needles no
paperwork when you apply for three
million in coverage or less just a few
questions about your health in an
application that's all you just need a
few minutes and a phone or a laptop to
apply ladders smart algorithms work in
real time not no dumb algorithm these
are smart algorithms that work in real
time you find out if you're instantly
approved no hidden fees you can cancel
at any time get a full refund if you
change your mind in first 30 days uh
finally since life insurance costs money
as you age now is the time to cross it
off make a move so go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage
ladderlife.com garbage do it mint mobile
baby I love that mint mobile you know
who else is sniffing around the Old Mint
Mobile Shop who's that Patty Foley Patty
Foley asking me all kinds of questions
is it real is it really of course it is
Patty I said yeah Patty it's 15 a month
baby plus they got those those family
lines and Patty Love saving a couple of
bucks saving a couple of bucks I'll tell
you that right now shout out to Mint
mobile they cut out the middle man they
passed the savings right on to you and
they got plans to start at 15 a month
what are we doing yeah guys right anyone
who hates their cell phone bill I know I
do I'm paying about 17 000 a day I think
but my wife the bird my wife's got mint
mobile she's been using mid mobile for
years way before this show even existed
Easy Living she had mint Mobile on it's
perfect it's the same thing mint mobile
gives you the best rate whether you're
buying one or for a family and Min
family started two lines all plans come
with unlimited talking text plus high
speed data delivered on Nation on the
nation's largest 5G Network use your own
phone and you keep your number the
contacts there's no like ah you can use
this flip phone or whatever whatever you
got you use same number same context
switch to Mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks 15 bucks let's go and here's the
gravy baby what do you got give me the
turkey to get your new Wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month and get that plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month that's crazy
mintmobile.com garbage do it do it well
you have the cake picked out is there a
cake yeah there's a chocolate and a
vanilla from what I've been told
Entenmann's what are you going with uh
an Italian woman from upstate New York
is doing it I think she might also be
doing the flowers I'm not sure Tommy's
wedding cinnamon roll did you ever find
out who's marrying you because at one
point my name was being thrown around
the ring a little bit no because I am an
ordained minister yeah I mean I assume
we have Celebrity Status at this thing
right what do you mean I mean VIPs yeah
right yeah you're gonna have bottle
service what are you talking about nice
okay yeah just want to make sure
um
what was the question and when he was
marrying you oh sorry no we don't know
yet I think maybe her aunt I mean you're
still in the running no I don't want to
be in the running you're still waiting
on swoop we actually want to interview
you get the [ __ ] out of here you got to
come to Queens I'm out I'm not going to
the wedding I'll send a joke I'll marry
you Tommy there you go I know too much
yeah you are not a fan of God okay
no thank you I'll marry you yeah I bet
you would
um but uh yeah no I would do it good
what are you talking about no we want
Kevin to come by we're gonna just it's
gonna be a few like uh just to make sure
that your like stamina is good we're
gonna I'm not dude I don't I've done it
once and it's just a lot of pressure
yeah I know for the like I didn't enjoy
though I did afterwards but it's like
the day's leading up and everything you
know yeah [ __ ] that dude as a comedian
it's always just better to like because
you judge everybody on like they're like
speech and stuff sure some of them
[ __ ] stinks some of them I've been to
a couple of years
he's getting in with a couple of jib
Jabs sure yeah yeah sometimes the proof
you get married in a in a church
sometimes the priest can lunch it too
sure I always judge the priest on the
homily you know a little the little
crowd work he does after he reads the
gospel one way to put it yeah sure are
you from what are you doing it's not
really the crowd work though that's like
the material yeah I guess well he reads
the gospel and then that's the materials
I'm not asking the lady what her social
security number it's riffing a bit
going off the Dome yeah that's
Corinthians huh all right let's get into
some [ __ ] please uh garbage Russian
guys when you sign up for patreon we
will answer your garbage question on the
air it's just the best way to do it the
patreons get first crack at it and shout
out to those sweet sweet homies over
there on patreon closing on 5 000
patrons baby not too much it's like a
small army to take over [ __ ] Roxboro
Finland
um all right this one's from Nicholas
have you ever Googled how to make money
I for sure have Googled how to make
money fast when I was real jammed up
well just like yeah and it's always the
same thing it's like surveys which those
things are [ __ ] First Step get a
printer yeah surveys uh focus groups
which I used to do a handful remember
that I would go do focus groups I do
remember you doing that and they were
paying [ __ ] gift cards they don't
tell you that you walk I'm like I can't
pay my rent with a [ __ ] 200 man can
you do a medical experiment too yeah I
had my hairline taken away
uh no but like there's also Craigslist I
used to find [ __ ] on Craigslist to do
you need cash quick sometimes yeah sure
absolutely don't I know it
um I don't know I Googled how to defrost
chicken yesterday but not money no or
like what did it say
did you put in the microwave to defrost
chicken yeah you got a uh warm water and
put the chicken in until it gets to a
certain temperature you needed a
computer if you could get to the bottom
of that on your own I'm not going to
this wedding I'm gonna [ __ ] catch
salmonella cooking the chicken who knows
I do have a lot of those YouTube things
come up of like uh like inspirational
ways to like not be a [ __ ] so I feel
like that's like you've done the right
it's a thing of how to shout out to the
other money no I don't think it's like
how to make money is like how to get
involved in real estate it's like how
can I get 50 bucks by tomorrow to pop a
bag you know what I mean sure
I remember being on the way back from
what's the The Comedy Zone in Harrisburg
I'd [ __ ] lost all my money I was just
[ __ ] so poor I quit my job to make it
a run at comedy
and I had like I needed like money and I
was just goo and I was like signed up
for all this stuff to get paid it was so
[ __ ] bad like give your opinion on
Triscuits and make three dollars and
fifty cents I was like doing that [ __ ]
there's something called not Roku but
ryko or Rico or something like that not
Rico I don't know
that uh I feel like my girl did it just
like you know for shits and giggles a
couple years ago it is something online
where you do like a survey or something
like that then they send you a check for
like 18 cents like three weeks later I
need it's my money and I need it now I I
signed up for like to be like a security
guard and like an art installation well
I know I ended up not pulling the
trigger and going because I think I
picked up a spot didn't pass the psych
test but I was going to go down and be
like standing like hey get your drink
off the whatever like I was but it was
like wear all black I don't think it was
the Mona Lisa got me worked at a museum
I mean because I worked at the Met yeah
I got fired for looking at my phone too
much
you've done this too where like you go
to like these things where you go to
game shows or like talk shows oh you
guys did do that now I didn't do I
didn't do it I wanted to go see yamanika
was on the show yeah I was a guest
Cassidy was a Steve Wilko regular I
would no not regular but I went you're
one of the black pack up there yeah
that's kicking the Tommy on the crowd
you're out there dude I definitely got
bedrooms on a bus let's back it up I
don't know if we talked about this on
your first one so in New York there's a
thing where they're shot in Connecticut
right yeah somewhere like that or like
the Jerry Springer Show The Steve Wilkos
Show and they need audience members and
you get on a bus you sign up you get on
a bus in New York at like Port Authority
or something right or Times Square Tommy
you are not the father
Tommy you are a loser and they ship you
up to Connecticut and give you like a
ham sandwich in like 18 bucks
what was the payment it's 50 I think no
it was like 100 or something or like 50
to 100
I think it was at least a hundred from
what I remember I've never done it this
was a long time ago okay it was like
three years ago it was like six years
ago you know what you get a little money
on patreon I should have never gave
these people money all right
my [ __ ] family I was waiting tables
three years ago but uh yeah I feel like
I got bed bugs on that bus man that was
that was a low of lows yeah you gotta
take bed bugs go into this [ __ ] Steve
Wilko show for a yeah for a tuna scene
you don't kill yourself after that it's
smooth sailing folks holy [ __ ] that's a
tough one oh that's bad Tommy had one of
the most
brutal jobs out of all of us coming up
he worked at tkts in Times Square
outside eight hours a day well during
one of the worst winners
I think on record it was bad remember
how colorful it was yeah I don't know
how you [ __ ] did that man it was a
dark dark time but uh I swear I met my
lady though too so we found love in a
hopeless place it was all worth it she
was dressed up as Elmo what was she she
was Wonder Woman
she dressed up like Batman she was uh
the top of the Statue of Liberty
did you get Steve Wilkos to marry you
there you go no but uh yeah that was
crazy it was so cold to where you would
be cold like hours afterwards because
you'd be like defrosting like a chicken
yeah uh all right this one's uh from
Geronimo ever referred to a security
guard as a rented cop while getting
kicked out of an event
[ __ ] rent a cop [ __ ] dude I only got
a gun I [ __ ] respect that a little
bit though a little bit because
sometimes those security guards can get
on their [ __ ] high horses yeah they
gotta get they gotta get their [ __ ]
cardboard especially at the mall yeah
yeah it's like what are you gonna know
the members are like I'll call the cops
it's like all right [ __ ] I'm not
waiting around you don't have
jurisdiction to hold me here
[ __ ] they don't help them out
with the uniforms either they should
hook them up they have real park ranger
Vibes I know and they're wearing like
the they're wearing like the hats that
they wear it like the [ __ ] hot dog
eating contest those like old-timey ones
the hot doggy the paper ones yeah like
the you know the hello my darling hello
they're like hats like that you know
what I'm talking about I don't think
barbershop quartet that's not that
official you're saying no that's a bad
look no I'll give you that and they
should have guns what no what you don't
want that guy with a gun I don't want
the guy who's protecting the [ __ ]
Auntie Anne's pretzel no way BB gun
maybe unless you got some nickel No
One's Gonna respect you yeah that's what
I'm saying you shouldn't even be there
I remember I got in trouble not in
trouble I think I might have said this
we were in Wildwood and during the
summer they have like these like
auxiliary cops or something they're
called where they're not like real
they're like summer cops to come in and
help with the crowd control I think the
word is racist and they don't have guns
or anything are they my I don't know but
the guy yelled at me not to I was like
on the curb and I fell into the street a
little bit like I like you know I was
all bombed up outside kanans flying all
over the place this episode weddings I
got a bit of a drinker problem get your
inner ear check
Kippy like the sauce I Heard It Go Vinny
over here
and like I like just misstep he's like I
said get on the curb and I turn around
he was like an 18 year old kid with like
freckles and I called him officer Harry
Potter and it [ __ ] dude every other
cop was like oh [ __ ] officer Potter I
was like oh man I just I [ __ ] ruined
your summer but yeah that's pretty good
cops love to intimidate like younger
people especially down the shore oh yeah
I remember getting pulled over and
they're like where's the drugs at
he's a kite right now yeah too late
um yeah we had a dude when I was when I
was a little kid uh Townline Townline
townhouse Community shout out do it uh
we were like playing by the creek or
something like that and this cop rolled
in and like just by coincidence when he
pulled in we like kind of like walked
the other way and he [ __ ] he's like
get over here and like dude this guy
scared the [ __ ] out of us he brings us
over for like no I think he was looking
to [ __ ] do a little finger job
he calls us over his me and my boy
Rodney uh Rodney yeah shout out to him
create it what's happening right uh you
invented the phrase it's all good it's
all good and I'll take that to my grave
um
brings us over starts [ __ ] grilling
us what he's doing what was under your
shirt this and that he like makes him
lift up his shirt makes me lift up my
shirt I'm listening yeah that's what I'm
saying it was like
all right
that one take your pants off turn around
and [ __ ] he asks us he's like what's
your name and where do you live and
Rodney coughed it up right away but I
knew there was something not right about
it but he's like uh he's like he's like
what's your address where do you live
and I was like why do you want that and
he [ __ ] lost it gets out of the car
[ __ ] gets in my face he's like
[ __ ] pressing up against me like I'm
up against the car he's like because I
asked for it now give me your address
[ __ ] took our address and then just
took off never [ __ ] heard about it
again
I think it was a cop real cop could have
been a trash man or something I think so
yeah he was it he was in a patrol car
and he had the uniform and all that
stuff could have been a stripper looking
for your mom he did have a Boombox
I don't know if those shorts were
government-issued or whatever
is that thong authorized hey man why do
you have glitter on your face
God's a squirt gun
um all right let's see here
foreign this is from Coco 10 homie here
haven't had one red is it garbage if
your dad has to tie your shoes at a
wedding because your pants are too tight
that's pretty bad yeah that means you
don't have the right kind of gear to
operate
there's got to be a heavy set guy
because one of you had to tie my shoes
recently right yeah I had to yeah they
called me a bad friend I'm [ __ ] tying
this guy's shoes
yeah like you're paraplegic or something
I thought you were good what that day
you were nice tie my shoes for me I
don't need you to do it no more though
so [ __ ] you he really likes to pull
shirt down I always have to pull this
shirt Down's a big thing you need like a
wardrobe team walking around it'd be
[ __ ] nice to tell you not to wear
that shirt
kind of easy this morning that's what
you're about to fight Godzilla I did see
you I a video of you wearing that came
around not too long ago like I just said
it was getting a story or something I
was like oh yeah that shirt and I
figured it had was long gone I didn't
know you were had it behind glass
waiting to break it back out dude my
whole [ __ ] closets that that's all I
got now I'm just finding [ __ ] Jam
after gem I wouldn't know I wouldn't
call that a gem all right
yeah that needs a little more pressure
before it's a diamond gotta hit the rock
tumbler a bit okay let's talk about Adam
and Eve I'm chubbing up at the sight of
the copy Toby Hit the Lights oh wait
gang we all know what Adam and Eve is we
all know what they're selling and we all
know you want it right now 50 off almost
anything they got on a website when you
use the promo code garbage and it's not
just that big man plus you get free
shipping yeah they're discreetly yeah
they should ship to your door it doesn't
say like dildos are us or anything
or whatever kind of weird stuff you're
into we're not judging and neither does
Adam and Eve they send it to your door
in a nice package people think you're
just getting toilet paper
delivered I like it over here maybe it's
something for the butt as well I don't
know that's up to you it's your
prerogative either way you're gonna be
walking funny whether it's for you and
the Mr you and the missus or just you
some of the little little kitty time
whatever you want they got it
penis pumps baby that's what I'm talking
I got one right here it's not my bag
Adam and Eve has it all and blow up
dolls that won't blow up your wallet
that's a good copy right there I don't
care what you say go to adamandeve.com
have some fun select any one item and
use code garbage uh this is an exclusive
offer uh specific to this podcast so be
sure to support our show and use code
garbage to get 50 off and free shipping
adamandeve.com right now uh support the
show by using Code garbage for 50 off
and free shipping at adamandeve.com now
back to the show too tight of his suit
is just weird that you can't bet you
would have to be too fat I guess but I
don't know man a pair a pair of tight
pants can really Jam you up and you
don't I hate it yeah I think give suit
pants get tight and I don't think you
realize how tight they are then and how
limited your motion and that that
material is thin those split pretty
easily [ __ ] yourself as a guy who split
a couple of pairs of pants in his day
right before he fell what do you think
made me feel his pants into goddamn
thing you're hopping on that [ __ ]
party bus and you [ __ ] go a little
[ __ ] long in the lake yeah and you're
done then what do you do what do you do
at the wedding you go back to the hotel
put on a pair of jeans
okay Bruce Willis yeah yeah no I saw him
banged up by the
Columbus Circle one day real funny one
in the afternoon like falling down the
stairs [ __ ] up coming out of that
French place that all those celebrities
go to right there to Columbus Circle
he's not Rue 57 no it's crazy coming out
of one that means he might have been
there since like the night before yeah
he was banged up [ __ ] kind of it
looked real good had like a top hat not
a top hat but like a hat on a [ __ ]
scarf it was like a winner he looked you
know you can tell a rich guy in the
winter because they're real put together
they got all the accoutrement they know
how to wear those scarves really good
that the scarves tied real [ __ ] tight
it's tucked in they got the matching
gloves the nine yards not wearing a
[ __ ] Eagles hat nope tie their shoes
yeah I don't think he could at the time
but you know uh all right this one's
from Andrew ten dollar ten dollar homie
conversion 1360 Canadian homie here nice
have you ever splashed them Splash
someone with your car on purpose
it's a dick move but kind of fun I gotta
give you if you're watching it it's a
good time yeah if you're the guy getting
Splash that's bad news yeah life's all
about timing I don't think I ever have I
have I've been [ __ ] up I've been hit
by somebody we're like oh that's I gotta
go home you know you can't [ __ ] show
up at the office that's a day changer
yeah I was a prime target when I was a
kid little fat kid standing there
waiting for the bus older kids driving
the [ __ ] high school I used to
[ __ ] light me up all the time
[ __ ] brutal oh my God hey why were
you waiting for the bus at that early in
the morning that don't make no sense I
was waiting for the bus and those kids
were driving those kids were always
going there first breakfast
I gotta open up McDonald's I imagine you
were a breakfast at school kid that's
real ashy no not really I don't because
they didn't really have it but no I saw
to the to the pond thing when I worked
at tkts which we mentioned earlier there
was these Chicago girls where they would
dress up like the people from Chicago
the movie the the things the Musical
Chicago they're like red stock not just
a couple of [ __ ] players from [ __ ]
no yeah yeah from the south side no not
fussy heard of them but anyway but
they're yeah they're all dialed up and
some of them like really play it super
serious like they're in the musical
while they're doing it and they're just
handing out flyers yeah a girl method
actor myself a girl dropped her Chicago
Flyers completely dressed like that
somebody timed it perfectly way I don't
know if they did it on purpose but like
a literal tidal wave hit this Broad and
she just got up and danced and like
danced it off yeah don't worry about it
it was amazing it was just like a robot
it was really stops it man that's the
illusion right there okay it doesn't
matter I'm going for it I got a stay in
character baby we used to uh uh
we used to egg cars a lot which was
always fun wait till we get drunk and do
it like idiots yeah egg and cars was
egging houses nothing to shake a stick
at either a good [ __ ] time I got got
one time remember I got hit bad these
dudes [ __ ] I was like 16 or are they
you got egged my car did okay I was just
driving down to a random road and
there's a line of trees and like three
like they just [ __ ] whitewashed my
windshield I couldn't see [ __ ] I had to
pull over and stopped you I was Flying
Blind but there was no way there was no
way for me to turn around it was like
perfect perfect execution of there was
no way I was catching them ever like if
I did turn around and try I'd have to go
through a neighborhood then loop back
around oh you could get the [ __ ] kicked
out of you now of course no I'm just
saying I wasn't gonna do that I'm saying
I respected I was like I got they
[ __ ] there was no no way for me to go
after them at all yeah we had this one
house in our neighborhood that was a
[ __ ] that was number one target it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] kids lived there and
the house had been egged so many times
that that particular Mischief Night his
dad was outside waiting in a car with a
cup of coffee oh and [ __ ] we rolled
through [ __ ] rolled down the streets
[ __ ] lobbed a couple at the house
[ __ ] laughed and we scurried off into
the night went to my boy Ernie's house
your face all right through my coffee in
your face now you're all in being a big
tattoo
[Laughter]
Rodney again it's like Pulp Fiction kind
of stand in the basement with the game
but you do some real medieval [ __ ] down
there but uh we go and sit on his porch
and all of a sudden this guy comes
walking out we ain't even thinking about
he's like huh
I don't know man shout out to Ernie's
mom she was this real old school Italian
lady she didn't give a [ __ ] yeah he
she's like Hey kid get the [ __ ] off my
porch we didn't do anything we weren't
even here we were here all night
real guinea [ __ ]
give me a close I'm gonna wash them get
the yolk out of your clothes cause he's
out in the back burning them like the
Irish you want something to eat give me
the watch too
kids are the [ __ ] yeah
the Russell don't forget your shoes
that's a real ride or die broad that one
yeah she was shout out to Mrs Ray to 70.
uh I think I've had to mention this at
some point my uh my mom took us out for
Mischief Night one year I think I
attacked that that's had to come up yeah
what yeah we wanted to go we were kids
what did she what did she have on our
[ __ ] costume what's going on
with a [ __ ] not trying to get made
um growing organic eggs
your mom yeah she's down there pulling
the honey pot on somebody
I'll lure him into the alley and you
kids jump them Sheely the [ __ ] Dead
Rabbits Jesus Christ
so yeah you're just like breaking into a
house you know
pulling a Cincinnati high-rise you just
steal a car or something
what were you armed with a [ __ ]
nickel what do you mean
a [ __ ] I had a uh no
how old are you by the way
25. that's wild you've never told this
what she took you out on Mischief man
what did you guys do
kill the homeless guy a couple of
Beginnings no it was real innocent I
think that's what started
it was all fun and games I tell you uh
set the neighbor's cat on fire no I
think we were very young we wanted to go
out so I think
we just did like
people we news had like toilet paper
somebody we know his house or something
in hindsight it was probably somebody
from work she had a grudge
don't worry the cleaning lady will fix
it right pieces of [ __ ]
it was more like I'm assuming she was
probably like hey I don't I don't there
was a big group of us with a couple of
parents probably some lady that ate her
yogurt
getting back at her how do you like that
Peggy yeah
Janet Rosie
in the apartment 5c is a [ __ ]
yeah I don't remember I don't remember
all the details but it didn't seem crazy
I think we like toilet paper in like
trees to like people we knew could you
take your own house you idiots
she took me to my dad's house she sets
you up she starts hanging you guys
should you [ __ ] in your dad's bed uh I
don't remember I don't think it was that
that it wasn't that uh you know I mean
that's crazy
yeah man we're trash I don't know what
you want from me he was a single mom
trying to figure it all out yeah I guess
so
that's wild that's one way to do it
Tommy you ever get any hijinks like that
you're a city kid
remember I got in trouble by my mom from
like looking at the place when I was
little like that was like the one time I
got in trouble as a as a child hey you
little creep we're talking about Mission
Coast video that's a little bit yeah
that you're repressed Irish sexuality
the temptation of the flesh
what are you looking at you like that
you little pervert I think I like tried
to like smash a mailbox once with like a
baseball bat when I was like like almost
in the 50s in like high school we tried
doing that and like the it was so like
hard to just [ __ ] hurt my arms and
hurt me I think I just tried once I was
like that hurt you had a weak bones
now uh but yeah so malnourished little
kid off the streets are Roxbury kids we
got baseball bat got bird bones
uh all right this one's from Brian long
time homie here never had one red
oh and one against mailbox yeah
two up two down
again
if only had such a gleam in his eye when
he said bird bones
hungry
uh I just want some Brian long time
homie here never had one red how garbage
is it to pose in front of a bar or
restaurant that has your name on it I've
definitely done it the Foley's never
miss an opportunity yeah you know we
have those Foley Estate wine glasses at
our house yeah I know I saw them yeah
and they were like the the O's missing
on one like it's a real bet two L's yeah
um yeah we have that uh anytime there's
a Foley bar any of our cousins sure
connected anybody when they're in
Ireland or whatever they said send them
back a picture look we're in fully I
know I did it I did I did it as an adult
in Germany we were at like there was
this
the Sullivan's Bar or something I want
and it's like you're such a dirt I just
I didn't even think of like it's not
even your last name that's my yeah but I
mean yeah but it's like uh just taking
front well I like send it to my mom like
look and like it didn't even register
that I'm like a grown man posing in
front of hey look show what it has the
same name as you she probably loved it
oh look she said
everybody got it so that was Patty Patty
to be angling like where are they from
are we connected do we get a pizza can
you go get a free beer how would you
know me
that's real bad yeah I've done it in
front of Tom's places and Cassidy's
places both absolutely first name that's
trash Tom's Place
there's times juice Tom's used auto
sales I mean times where they filmed or
Seinfeld the outside is that too yeah I
think so that's what it was called on
Seinfeld right no it was called
restaurant yeah it's it's Tom's
Restaurant sorry gotcha also known as
monks yeah shout out to monks made a
hell of an omelette
uh this one's from DJ Van Damme have you
ever had a family member you didn't know
existed reach out to you on social media
hmm I can't say I have but my I do run
into I do meet people still
I was at like uh I was at my
grandfather's funeral not too long ago
and someone's like this is [ __ ]
Terry's cousin Jimmy who's whatever yeah
he's like hey how you doing you're like
hey what's up
those Foley records are sealed right oh
yeah my boy Kyle wrote up on you custody
[ __ ] couple 23andme's [ __ ] I
[ __ ] told him not to do it but
sleeping dogs lie you know what I mean
sure my friend Kyle wrote up on you was
like I played baseball with your cousin
yeah like that type of stuff sure yeah
you know there's yeah there's six
degrees of Stevie Ryan
well I mean between the dirtbags I come
from and Roxboro and Kensington it's
like it's a very it's like a spike you
can't make it in Philly if you ever like
kicked a soccer ball in Philly I'm
somehow related to you I can't remember
if we talked about the last time I was
here but the my grandfather had the
thing on his deathbed where his aunt
told him that he was a Foley because his
mom had an affair with a Foley yeah you
didn't know that Toby this could be the
ultimate plot twist now you guys are
related we've talked about it before
it's possible yeah we talked about it on
the air how was it disputed
um
bully doesn't want to give us any money
yeah to the whack estate
he now owns four percent of the patreon
or something Genie stop calling me
better lawyer up
[Laughter]
but no yeah it's a pretty crazy story
like my grandfather was like meeting his
aunt who's on her deathbed and she told
him that his mother had an affair
your cousin is it fat [ __ ] fat [ __ ] a
bad t-shirt he was apparently a carpet
salesman uh yeah he was no I don't know
but I mean
wait they would be in the similar area
reverse that okay who was on his
deathbed the grandfather no the grand my
grandfather found out by I guess his
aunt I'm sorry on her deathbed or
something in that area okay it was
revealed to him much later in life that
his mother had an affair with a Foley
yeah so and that so he wasn't the father
well no he would have been his mom
wasn't of
his mom had a different dad who was a
Foley that's the thought meaning his
father was a Foley yeah right correct
who he thought his father was
was not it was in fact a Foley was fat
you guys are real [ __ ] ticks I tell
you he has a real parasites like Hydra
yeah you're like Ivy you get you get in
and you start [ __ ] taking over around
them ruining the host I'd love to
Quantum Leap into that huh see how that
all went down I love that show I wish
they would remake that shot why don't we
do a DNA test between you two to see if
there's any crossover
and that would be crazy wouldn't it I
don't think I have any DNA
[Music]
we need a DNA sample you just start
shoving up we're like nah dude a hair
hair Works anything saliva I don't know
I'm not leaving my cups around you guys
um this one's from Sideshow Bob ever
watch a hat
yeah it doesn't work yeah you can't do
it they have those things put them in
yeah but that's like come on I don't
know what that fully were I don't know
it doesn't it shrinks them up shoes and
hats are one of the things that you like
once you wash it it's never I just back
to its original thing all right just
washed these sneakers this weekend it
doesn't get the the material changes
it's the same as a t-shirt a t-shirt
changes from the first time you wear it
after you wash it it's because it's
chemically changed I'll give you that so
it's like how'd you drive where did you
wash them in the washer uh I used my
mom's spray on them first these sneakers
that I have on because it has that
grease that grease strip that just
[ __ ] won't come out I sprayed them
with her solution that she does I let
them sit in the Sun for a couple hours
and she washed them hit them again yeah
and then put them outside
they're they're perfect we can wash them
like in the washer in the washing
dishwasher oh that's so gross to me why
then you put like your utensils in there
the dog licks all that [ __ ] off
yeah I don't know it's contaminated to
me that's scalding hot water nothing
surviving that I wish I could wash hats
though except for now fully you can't it
is a shame yeah get a new [ __ ] hat
just get new shoes just said you had a
grease stain on your shoes for months
that won't come out I like these though
they're like the most generic pair of
Reeboks or something you look like you
got ran your foot got ran over by a
cartoon truck yeah you do you are not a
white shoe kind of they're not that bad
they're bad I'm six feet away from you
they're bad I'd like you to stop wearing
them because they're too similar to mine
I'm gonna buy three more pair
please they won't have to probably come
with grease stains on pick up a pair
afterwards
after what you just you just make
statements that don't make any
after we're done recording Foot Locker
I'm coming
get the hors d'oeuvres ready
uh this one's from Josh new homie here
haven't uh have you ever frequented a
bar where regulars had their own usual
seat at the bar and get mad if someone
else was sitting there yeah yeah
definitely have that in my in my home my
hometown Watering Hole but I you can
always walk when you walk into a bar
like that you can sense the vibe of like
oh this is real
[ __ ] regular [ __ ] I'm real aware of
that and I I stay away all right where
I'll take a booth or [ __ ] whatever
yeah stay away from the [ __ ] regular
corner you walk in everybody looks at
you yeah
there's that guy in Atlantic City after
that one show we did you know that old
bar fly who I feel like is always in
there at that bar yeah the Irish Pub
yeah I was there last week shout out to
it was that guy there
I don't think so because I was sitting
in a seat but that guy but also too like
guys like that well that guy was like
counting our money and stuff uh who's
paying for the drinks like he was like
real in the financial uh going ons of
our our group we had going on maybe he
was a planner so we bought him a drink
or something a kid you know keep his
nose up I think we ordered a round of
shots for us and he's like what am I
skip or something or must be nice hey
Old Man Winter's [ __ ] hey Old Timer
get you a bowl of soup hit the bricks
will you I'm trying to [ __ ] the chicks
here
you're talking to your cousin
yeah oh that's right you did have family
there you're cute uh all right this
one's from Chris Dunn first question
have you ever had a family member ever
had anything to do with a dunk tank I've
been in a dog tank before you've been in
one of course where
um Las Vegas what no you answered of
course like you have them at your
barbecues we used to do uh we were big
in the 90s like that was like not at the
barbecue I'm saying you answered oh you
were like uh of course like you have
them every weekend it was uh I think the
Montgomery County Horse Show which there
was no horses which was weird they used
to do it you were like the [ __ ] show
for a little bit huh s was soft for a
minute the horse show yeah strip club
yeah
um it was like uh it was it was some
scam the church did the [ __ ] raise
money touch the little boys what are you
talking about the 50 50 scratchers some
funnel cake and a dunk tank and a dunk
tank you got in yeah because I was an
altar boy they put us in there second
worst thing that happened here that day
did you get dunked did you get sank yeah
a bunch of times was it holy water no
it's [ __ ] dirty [ __ ] ice cold
water always it was in November I
remember Jesus yeah dude I was sick for
like a week there was the guy in
Wildwood who did it like in one of the
far away Piers it was Portland Pier we
would go at like 20ish and he was mean
oh the meanest man [ __ ] can't hit
what you can't see this guy has scarred
Kevin yes oh dude yeah he got it he's a
scar dude you've mentioned this multiple
times oh yeah it was a clown yeah called
you fat ass oh dude he would get hurt
whatever your nationality was he was
going after it regardless of PC like he
was good yeah he was like an insult
comic exactly imagine imagine Rickles
but mean drinking all day but yeah but
meme is behind a cage and has face paint
on yeah
everybody dude that was that's how you
closed up you'd be calling her a dumb
word too listen here what do you would
you would the dad run away like all this
[ __ ] yeah he was he was Ruth and he was
worse than that oh yeah he was like all
1991 like yeah like there's a
documentary about him on YouTube tube
interesting what was his name
I didn't think it was HBO
I wasn't Netflix that really is the
Bottom Rung of Show Business though
isn't it yeah an insult dunk guy who did
the doc Ken Burns what are we talking
about here but he was vicious and that
was such a big I loved it like [ __ ]
loved loved I was scared oh I threw a
couple of times early on I'm like maybe
and then it was rigged too like that you
couldn't like the spot you had to hit
was like that big and the rest was like
loose rubber so if you hit it it would
just like go through it yeah and every
time he got hit he would come back up
and go high and dry orange can't hit
what you can't see he told my brother
because my brother had big ears he told
my brother he looked at me on that he
looked like a Cadillac going down Broad
Street with the doors open or something
like that like he was [ __ ] hit me
with that too
I was terrified of that dude
yeah I was terrified of clowns in
general I didn't [ __ ] with them when I
was yeah this one looked like yeah dude
he was just sitting there smoking
cigarettes no no they took it because
the makeup never came off and be in the
water he was like the Joker he was real
Joker like even mean meaner Joker yeah
the makeup oh dude he was scary and then
we learned he would he would he would
leave with a police escort at the end of
the night Under the Boardwalk
the people were waiting for him and they
were like yeah the cops were like dude
he left an hour ago man that is crazy
isn't it people would wait to beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of him sounds like a
real good time man in the 90s different
times
the Dracula Castle
there was literally a Dracula Castle on
its own there's huge it was a haunted
house and this guy was trying to scare
like a teenager like you know the guy in
there like jumped out and he was like ah
and the guy's like you can't scare me
[ __ ] so he goes I'll get him so he went
somewhere like it wasn't supposed to be
that like the actor did the guy working
and there was like some sort of
spring-loaded like thing that shot out
and his leg was in the spring and just
cut him off at the knee and the kid and
the kid in the [ __ ] ride got blood
all over him he's like ah yeah whatever
he thought it was fake really the guy's
got his [ __ ] leg cut off had to take
him out on a stretcher they need a
documentary on that place too if they
don't got one it was a kid who was
working for the summer from Ireland yeah
yeah it's literally a Foley yeah
this is deeper than I thought we're all
over that place yeah I want to borrow
money
holy [ __ ] I thought that was pretty good
all right we gotta wrap it up Tommy yes
we [ __ ] love you love you pal check
it out I can't make the wedding God
bless new album
funny life after funny not on YouTube
right now yeah yeah streaming services
tomorrow streaming services July 15th
tomorrow Friday doing all the live shows
with us out there on the road everybody
[ __ ] loves time great times man
everybody's been so awesome thank you
guys for having me on the road in here
today it was so much fun of course thank
you buddy and we'll see you guys all in
Red Bank New Jersey on August 11th make
sure you get those tickets because it's
creeping sell out coming everywhere
Philly Boston Providence the whole nine
yards gonna be a good time gang we
[ __ ] love you and we'll see you next
week